Hello everyone,
this is the lane focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Thank you for tuning in.
Okay.
When refining and improving your own
approach to learning languages,
it's always great to look at people who
have done it before.
People have already done it very
successfully and model what they're
doing,
copy what they're doing,
copied their strategies for learning and
their approach to learning,
their attitudes,
to learning all of those things.
I've met a lot of people who are great
with languages while traveling and also
in my regular life and I'd like to talk
about a couple of particularly
impressive people that we can learn
something from now.
This goes back to my first time visiting
Egypt in 1997.
I was in a backpack of resort called the
hub and I met a number of Bedouin girls
who were there just selling bracelets
that were selling little trinkets,
souvenirs to tourists like me.
We would go and sit on the beach and
these little beach side restaurant,
a cushions laid out on the beach.
People would serve you food and these
better when girls would just wander in
off the street and try to sell us
bracelets.
Now what was interesting was I sat there
and I watched these girls switch between
multiple different languages in the
space of like five minutes.
I would give them,
speak English with lots of people.
Then they would switch to French without
skipping a beat and then they would
switch to Spanish.
They would switch to Italian,
they would switch to Hebrew,
they would switch to numerous different
languages.
German,
uh,
I think I even heard them speak Korean
and Japanese now.
I was wondering how would these young
girls,
like eight year old bedouin girls who
probably don't have much education,
how would they be able to speak eight
different languages or 10 different
languages or whatever it was.
So that got me thinking about what makes
them successful and great with
languages.
So how do they do it?
How do these eight year old Bedouin
girls learn languages way better than
your average college student in the
Western World?
Well,
I think there were three main areas that
I identified that we can learn from when
we look at these girls.
The first one is obviously their
motivation,
right?
They have a strong economic incentive to
learn that language.
They come from a poor background.
They live in a poor area or your only
source of income.
Their source of their livelihood is
tourism.
They have to speak foreign languages in
order to get by and the more languages
they can speak,
the more potential customers they can
communicate with,
the more money they bring up,
so they have that economic incentive.
Most of us living in the west,
we already have quite a cushy existence.
We can't quite imagine what it's like to
have that economic motivation to learn.
One of the interesting things I've heard
about these young kids who are selling
souvenirs is that they're not allowed to
go home to their house until they sell a
certain amount of souvenirs.
They can't go home and have dinner until
they sell 20 bracelets or something like
that.
So imagine that they have that positive
incentive of making money,
but they also have that negative
incentive of being punished basically
for not selling enough.
So that really motivates them to just do
whatever it takes.
Right.
So they have no excuses,
they make no excuses for themselves,
they just go out and do it because they
have to.
They really have choice.
So they find whatever it takes,
whatever resources they have inside
themselves to learn.
Now that's quite different from your
average western person who whines and
cries and says,
I can't learn languages.
It's too hard.
It takes too much time.
I have to study.
I want to watch TV instead of these kids
actually go out and just do it because
they have no choice.
And if you decide to do that,
you can do that too.
So that's one thing we can learn from
them.
It's not only these better when kids
either.
I mean in other developing countries
I've been to.
I've noticed the same thing when I was
in Cambodia,
when I was in Indonesia when I was in
Thailand.
People who just have that economic
incentive,
they don't have the same mental blocks
toward learning languages that people
enrich countries do.
They just do whatever it takes.
They have that survival mentality and
they just go for it.
The second thing is that they're skilled
are based in practical experience right
from the start.
They're not sitting at home or sitting
in a classroom getting kind of
theoretical experience or simulated
experience.
They're out there getting real
experience face to face with people
using the language right from the start.
Now that's different from the way most
of us learn.
We might learn from textbooks or in a
classroom.
We're learning theoretically in a
simulated sort of context and then later
when we have a certain level of the
language,
we go out and try to apply it with real
people.
That's kind of how most of us tend to
learn languages or typical people in the
western languages,
but these kids,
they go out right from the start and
they're getting that experience now.
Why is that good?
If you're at home studying with a book
or you're in a classroom listening to
your teacher and looking at the
Whiteboard,
you're getting some sort of visual
input.
You're getting some auditory input to
some extent.
You're using those learning modalities,
but you're not really getting as much
hands on kinesthetic experience of
actually using the language and feeling
what it's like to use the language and
when you get out there in the real
world,
in a real situation,
it's very visually stimulating because
you're looking at an entire scene
surrounding you.
You're seeing different things.
You're seeing,
you're hearing the real sounds of an
interaction that you have the real world
around you.
It's not a simulated experience like you
get with your textbook at home or in a
classroom.
You're out there in the real world and
also you are getting the kinesthetic
experience so you know what it feels
like to use the language and you get a
certain emotional feeling when you
interact with that person and you also,
you can feel physically what it's like
to use your body language and to
actually physically interact with that
person you're communicating with.
Now all of that creates a kind of a kind
of memory and experience that includes
all of those different learning
modalities and it's much easier to
remember than when you're learning just
from a book or from the classroom.
I can remember experiences that I had
using languages years and years ago.
I remember I have a memory of a
situation 15 years ago in Jerusalem when
I was there studying Hebrew and Hebrew
course.
An acquaintance of mine came into the
room and he said,
what most of the MTA when I was studying
and and that means you're not finished
yet.
And I said,
Lord,
mostly empty.
And they buy.
That means,
no,
I'm not finished yet.
I'm in the middle of studying.
I remember that interaction and I
remember the whole scene.
I can see that room and I can see him
come into the room and I can hear the
intonation in his voice and I remember
kind of feeling taken aback by it.
The way he said it.
It sounded like,
what?
You're an idiot.
You're not finished yet.
It was that kind of intonation.
So I remember that whole feeling of the
experience.
Now that's the benefit of going out into
the real world and really using the
language.
You're encoding it into your physiology,
right?
It's a kinesthetic experience that you
can recall as a memory.
The memories are more powerful than
memorization.
That's how I like to think of it.
Now,
the third thing that these girls do well
is that their use of the language is
very functional and it's goal oriented.
They're not just learning the language
for the sake of learning it.
They're not just learning it so they can
say,
Hey,
I'm fluent in 10 languages.
It's not an ego based approach to
learning.
They don't feel like they have to learn
absolutely everything about the
language.
What is their goal?
Their goal is to sell.
That's their main function or main point
for using that language and that's what
they focus on when they're learning.
So basically they want to sell to you
and they're following a straight line
from meeting you to selling to you.
The line ends when you buy something,
all of the language they learn is
basically just language.
They need to follow that straight line
and they can veer off the line a little
bit and have a little bit of chatting
time with you and they can ask some
questions about where you're from and
they can talk to you about some casual
topics,
but when they get too far off of that
line too far away from their focused
goal of selling to you,
then they probably aren't that good at
communicating because that's not the.
That's not where they focus their
studying and focus their attention.
So they'll always bring their attention
back to that straight line of trying to
sell to you.
Right.
And all of their language is focused
around that.
So that's basically why they can speak
10 different languages at such a young
age because they're not learning
absolutely everything about the
language.
They're learning the grammar and the
structure of the language basically.
And they're learning the basic
vocabulary of language.
Everything they need to sell to you and
to communicate with you and chat with
you and build rapport with you.
And that kind of thing,
but if you start talking about widely
divergent subjects that have nothing to
do with the sale and nothing to do with
getting to know you well enough to make
the sale happen,
then they're not going to be that good
with the language.
So basically they're very focused on
what they're using the language for and
they have the basic structures of the
language in place.
So if in the future if they needed to
learn it for a different function,
they can always add that extra
vocabulary,
add those extra structures that they
need on top of what they already know.
But they don't try to learn everything
at once.
They just learn what they need.
Right.
So in terms of your study,
think about what you need to use the
language for.
You really need to learn absolutely
everything about the language or do you
just want to use it for a specific
purpose?
Like getting to know friends,
like making some friends,
being social in that language.
Do you need to use it for a specific
business purpose?
Do you need to write emails in that
language?
Whatever your purpose is,
maybe you should focus on that rather
than trying to tackle the entire
language in one big goal.
Now it's also worth pointing out that
these kids don't really worry about
perfection at all.
A lot of them speak with kind of funny
grammar.
They don't speak accurately,
but they communicate.
They understand you,
you understand them,
so it's all good.
They can achieve that goal that they
have for the language.
Now,
the benefit that has for learning is
that you don't slow yourself down.
You don't put yourself into a bit of a
panic worrying about all the details and
worrying about perfection.
Being a perfectionist can puts you in
into a non ideal learning state.
It can make you stressed,
right?
Anxiety and stresses the antithesis of
learning.
You want to avoid it like the plague,
always relaxed.
You can continue improving your accuracy
and continue to self monitor and fix
your your mistakes and all that,
but don't worry about it.
Just keep on learning and keep your goal
in your functions for the language in
mind,
just like these girls do and you'll
learn a lot better.
So what can we learn from the eight year
old Bedouin kid?
Well,
number one is no whining,
no excuses,
just go for it.
Find what motivates you and do it.
Number two is get real experience from
as early on as possible.
Don't do all your studying and simulated
experiences,
simulated situations.
Don't do all your studying with books.
Get real experience with real people as
early as you can.
And the third thing is,
know your main purpose for learning the
language.
Do you really need to know absolutely
everything about the language?
Do you just want to make friends in the
language?
Do you want to use it for a specific
purpose?
Focus on your purpose for that language
and put your attention there.
Then later in the future,
if you need to add extra functions and
extra purposes for the language you can,
but focus on what you need it for and
that will really accelerate your
learning because you're not paying
attention to things you don't really
need to do.
So if you ever think that you can't do
it,
that you can't learn a language that
you're not good with languages or
whatever.
Just remember all those kids in
developing countries who learn languages
quite well because they,
they just go for it and they have no
mental block to learning it,
so if they can do it,
you can do it.
Don't even stress just to go for it.
Alright,
this is Paul.
Thank you for watching.
Have a good night and see ya.
Hello everyone.
Thank you for tuning into laying focused
TV.
I am your host Paul,
and tonight we're going to talk about
the difference between informal and
formal language and which one you should
focus on learning when you're learning a
new language.
Another awesome benefit of meditation
for language learning is that it helps
you with your listening comprehension.
So when you're listening,
often there's something that's blocking
you are getting in your way.
Now what I mean is this.